the nba
they took a very clear-cut line stance
on blm
social justice their ratings kind of
tanked yeah i mean my heat were in the
final so i was good with that all but
lakers the one that won the finals la so
sum that all up how i mean are you a
lebron guy are you not a lebron guy are
you part of the social justice how do
you
how do you deal with all that there's
different perspectives on all that
well my perspective is i'm going to
exist in my own particular free will in
my own space i believe
uh i i love lebron's skill set i love
his
personal agenda on how he's orchestrated
his family and also his friends that
he's put around him he has a great
blueprint for other people to follow
i'm just not aligned with his political
beliefs and some of the things that he's
done
and how he has used his platform i've
actually reached out to him via
instagram because i would love to have
a different conversation with them when
you're at that height in that particular
level you have certain people around you
and i was a democrat by default right
and they took for someone to kind of
like enlighten me on what
happened to you four and a half years
ago who was that that sat down with a
gentleman by the name of cole harris he
ran for lieutenant governor of
california that was my entry into
politics
what was the selling what was the what
did he say to you that you flipped
so we're in his backyard at a birthday
party at his house
and he leaned over to me and said i'm
going to be running for lieutenant
governor the first thing i said what is
that i didn't even know what lieutenant
that's four and a half years ago yeah
four and a half years ago
pre-trump yes okay well right around the
same time so is it fair to say you were
an obama guy at least until that point
oh absolutely okay
but from the just by default was it
because i can remember any kind of great
policies because they don't exist right
um and then we sort of then we started
going like that line right there
boom boom then we started going down the
rabbit hole of
of policy and what i was able to
identify as a free thinker as
it was a policies that was beneficial
and also detrimental but then i was able
to apply that to how i grew up
so my mother used to tell me that the
government loved us but what she really
meant was democrat loved us
the democrats loved us simply because of
the welfare check she was getting right
so as a kid
and your mother is telling you this
they're protecting us so i feel
they're they're for us but there is a
ceiling right people
you know you don't understand that at
that particular point conservatism for
me
and and my cole harris i'm speaking
about
it was explained simplistically
simplistically like republicans and
conservatives we rather show you how i
made that hundred dollars
versus give you that 100 because that
empowers you
you know i love what you said about
lebron because i think that would be a
great strategy for you because
whether you like lebron's politics or
not and he's very polarizing and he's
really really gone really far lately but
he's brilliant he's smart i mean he
can't argue with that and i don't think
he'd have a lot of arguments against you
and i think if you could have a
reasonable conversation that's what you
started
my thing is if black lives do matter
lebron yeah you should at least talk to
me i'm making history
but you have so much credibility to have
that conversation with him and hopefully
he'd be
allow himself to listen yeah because you
would not have a bigger megaphone and if
you don't go
go to maverick carter you know he's an
entrepreneur just like you yeah go
go to those guys and stay at them
because that would be a great have you
heard back from their camp at all
not yet but i do need to reach out to
the additional individuals like maverick
and also rich paul as well too
because like i said i love their story i
like the fact that he
empowered them and made them get
educated to come on board to help him
run his organization and whatnot and if
they're actually interested in
making an impact making a change they
should sit down and have a conversation
with you
right because what we've seen is if you
don't speak you like
you know to use a uh international
relations you don't make peace with your
friends you make peace with your enemies
and i'm not saying that you guys are
enemies
but finding some common ground
especially you running as
for governor it would be it would be
very advantageous for you guys
tell lebron you need to get into the
barber shop i mean really that show was
created
that was created for debate i mean if he
had guts he'd invite you right into that
right now
and i would go i would actually maverick
seems like the kind of guy that would
bring you
likelihood of that happening likelihood
of that i'm going to hold out hope i'm
going to say 30 percent
likelihood of that happening give me a
percentage likelihood of lebron actually
putting him at the ball because lebron
likes to be challenged so let's see if
he's going to respond to him
likely likely likelihood of this
happening and him reaching out because
by the way there was another lapd
officer that reached out to lebron as
well to have a private one-on-one
yeah big guy i don't know what is i
don't know if you saw that or not this
was last week
likelihood of lebron i'm an optimist i i
really like major's
message i i think he could relate to
lebron 51
he should because we come from very
similar backgrounds right uh
single parent household grew up in
poverty you know we're both
entrepreneurs
both entrepreneurs both were willing to
uh sacrifice ourselves and
and work hard and and just really want
to do well he created the school that
was a great thing i have my non-profit
major kicks for kids
we give away over a thousand pair of
shoes every single year 2 000 haircuts
put on
empowerment events for the for the next
generation why do you think
that someone like lebron or someone as
outspoken as any of these nba leaders as
it ex
has not come over to your way of
thinking as an example you said i mean
the the facts
can you tell me the first time ever
lebron sat with an opposing argument
like when have you ever seen lebron
still with an opposing argument yeah
when he sat with uh the guy about uh
coming down to south beach i'm taking my
town to south that's not that's not
opposing though well you got a lot of
backups
i'm trying to tell you but but i'm what
i'm trying to tell you is when was the
last time he sat with somebody
that poses what was it the fact that i'm
taking my talents to south beach that's
not opposing
it's not bad there's backlash because of
a decision but what i'm asking you is
when is the last time conversationally
that he sat down with somebody that
opposes
on camera on camera probably not a lot
but i assume behind closed doors he'll
have
yes people that
screw you pat me maverick and rich will
sit with him i hope he says you have no
clue what the hell you're talking about
what i do behind closed doors phenomenal
i'll go out there and i was wrong great
but i'm telling you right now the
chances of that happening is less than
five percent yeah
on the media but behind closed doors
less than five percent of even him even
meeting with major williams behind
closed doors becky right now major
williams you win there
he's in there baby
no no this is not about him i know
back to my original question why is
lebron a democrat why is he
so outspoken anti-trump are you on team
trump that's a part b
question and why are a lot of the nba
guys democrats explain that why aren't
80 90
of african-americans democrats well the
thing about it is as i said earlier in
my conversation it's really by default
right
if you're cultivated under the mindset
that they are for you at a very early
age you take that into your your teenage
years your early adult years and your
later years if you're not
informed correctly as pat was saying if
you're surrounded by
yes men and and and and people who just
agree you're saying that black people in
general or more the lebron
the black culture is strongly indebted
to uh
you know the democrat policy and you're
saying that that it's um
what was the word you used indebted or
what was the other word you said that
it's by default by default
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye